America is plunging into chaos and our
leaders have gone AWOL Congress getting
sent back home for a nice relaxing
weekend after voting to kick out speaker
Kevin McCarthy meanwhile the Border
crisis is Raging with a new record for
Crossings and it's so bad that even
liberal leaders are demanding that
something needs to be done
disturbing violence continues to make
the Streets Run red and blue cities like
this video of a man being randomly
stabbed to death on New York streets oh
and of course the government runs out of
money next month and lawmakers are just
pointing fingers over who is at fault
for not having a speaker
I think today was a political decision
by the Democrats but eight people can
partner with the whole other side
how do you govern and they did
absolutely nothing to reach across the
aisle they are captive to Donald Trump
and the extreme Maga Wing the house has
been doing its job at the most point but
we miss key deadlines and we shouldn't
have taken a six week recess there are
too many challenges that the country are
facing to have the house continue to be
in chaos the crime problem the Border
problem Democrats have figured it out so
let's come together and focus on that
agenda as Republicans keep the
government running over any of these
other little things because that's the
fundamental part of our job I see
literally hundreds of members of
Congress acting like Nero fiddling while
Rome Burns whistling by the graveyard
this has got to change in fiddling
and Mr adult in the room Joe Biden
thinks this is all a big joke
advice to the next next house speaker
so Jesse should we just fire the mall
and start over yeah just clean house
Gutfeld speaker you've already nominated
him I'm in and I know why the country's
running out of money because I just
looked at the requests AOC wants a half
a million dollars for a bathroom in the
Bronx
Nancy wants five million dollars for an
elevator in San Francisco how about this
one how about a bird sanctuary to reduce
emissions for a cool 1.5 million or even
better how about EV Chargers in the
projects because every time I drive by
the projects I can't stop seeing the
Tesla's breakdown oh there's more how
about planting trees and grass in a
parking lot
I have my landscaper gave me a quote for
sod and trees he'd probably do it for
about fifty thousand dollars they asked
for a million dollars a million dollars
for grass and trees a playground
three million dollars for a playground I
went on Amazon today I can get a
playground for Jesse Jr for about five
grand it's got the slide it's got the
tire swing why are you spending so much
money and I'll tell you Katie the donors
give these guys the money to get elected
and then they take our tax dollars and
then they just plow it back to the
donors in the form of pork and so Gage
said let's stop it McCarthy said I can't
stop it I only have a couple seats in
the margins here and so they just blew
it up like a kamikaze pilot are we ever
gonna get spending under control
probably not and that's the issue and
then they stress about keeping the
government open so they can keep that
right
the government shuts down
um Greg should these lawmakers stay home
more often and do less it's not like a
good thing maybe I don't care I'm more
interested in the crime element of this
segment which is really sad and
disturbing you saw two beloved left-wing
activists murder the past week
I'm beginning to think that the filter
that Progressive leaders force on other
people is deadly that you better not
cross the street when you see a crazy
man because well that's racist you need
to always prove that you're enlightened
by risking your life I'm not a
progressive I'm a realist which means I
assess my surroundings untethered to any
ideology that means I just I
discriminate I cross the streets I avoid
sketchy areas I don't put the lives of
others in Jeopardy of a potential psycho
because I fear CNN might call me a bigot
most people in New York City have
changed their habits to accommodate risk
they stand at the rear of the subway
platform they avoid bad areas even
though that might be called by a
progressive as racist it's not the
activist's fault for being killed they
allied with a with a filter that denies
the reality and instructs you to throw
caution to the wind because that that's
anti-racist progressivism is actually
now killing progressives this is an
ideology that needs a warning label
right you and by the way have you heard
any progressives calling for justice no
and why not I don't know they don't even
like giving descriptions of the suspects
to the police because that's racist they
don't like pictures of them in
newspapers their brains have been
modified to believe that they are
servants deserving of punishment lastly
I want to make this point it's a little
controversial I don't care
we fought a war to end slavery and why
because apparently we couldn't decide to
end it peacefully right we knew it was a
moral evil yet we allowed ourselves to
engage in a war to end it because the
Democrats clung to it doesn't that sound
familiar now that we have vicious crime
without and a Relentless cycle there's
no end in sight Mad Men prowl the
streets they carjack they kill people
you have violence as an acceptable
reality and yet it's a moral evil
that the left is okay with it's almost
as if we're gonna have to fight a war to
bring peace it's scary so Jessica has
the leftist ideology of being afraid of
being called a racist now put the left
in this position where you have a
serious problem and there's not a lot of
solutions coming from the left in fact
there's more funding for these
Progressive DA's than ever before
I don't think that that's the root cause
of the problem here I think that people
have readjusted their behaviors and
Democrats that I talk to and I'm not
part of the activist class which I think
is out on an island by themselves I'm
part of the normal Democratic class and
we talk about changes that people have
made in their lives that you you know
your stuff is locked up at the CVS that
you do behave differently if you go on
the subway some don't even go on the
subway
um to begin with
there is nothing comparable going on
right now to slavery and that's what
you're quarreling with
well
an analogy is always imperfect that's an
analogy well I think it's so imperfect
that perhaps it shouldn't have been made
in this case because you have people in
Boston I won't do it again
that is a lie you will do it probably
again today I'm going to do it in the
e-block
that's mine all right do whatever you
want it's the fastest
um
but this is about the shutdown actually
or the impending shutdown and what
happened with the speakership and you
said oh would it be so bad if we weren't
doing all this spending what happens
when the government shuts down shuts
down which is the most important part is
that employees federal employees are not
paid these are people paid it doesn't
matter if you live paycheck to paycheck
waiting however long it takes to get
that money doesn't help you and the both
sidesism about this is astounding Kevin
McCarthy has a lot of gall getting up
there and blaming democrats for this who
first of all bailed them out over the
weekend to get that continuing
resolution and then he didn't even
bother to call them up and say what can
I do to get your vote I'm projecting
that five to eight or whatever are going
to go against me call up moderates call
up people like Dean Phillips who's
already talked about supporting a
republican speaker make a bid for it
Hakeem Jeffries may have said that the
price was too high but that doesn't mean
that you couldn't have picked off a few
individual members or at least made the
effort he just wants to continue to lie
about what went on there Hakeem Jeffries
gave Democrats marching orders not to
vote for Kevin McCarthy he is not ours
to save you know what he's not here's
the amazing part of this is that the
Democrats for weeks karees Jean-Pierre
the Republicans are going to shut down
the government nobody's going to get a
paycheck we're not going to be able to
pay bills ordinary Americans the
horrible Republicans then what happens
is you get Kevin McCarthy who avoids the
shutdown he avoids the shutdown he does
whatever he's got to do to avoid it and
what did the Democrats do they vote all
of them in unison to hang Kevin McCarthy
we save that no no you didn't save him
really on Saturday you were you sunk
Kevin McCarthy now stop it right now the
Democrats stick with each other the
Republicans would shoot within the tent
and that is the problem and at a time
when we've got crime with no solution
nobody cares the progressives are the
one who brought in these uh these Soros
funded DA's the Progressive Democrats
are the ones who said we don't want bail
we want these criminal dirtbags running
around town and and and re-victimizing
other people they're not solving the
problem so what do they do they're
reveling in the chaos and the
dysfunction of the Republican party and
they're laughing their asses off and
high-fiving each other excuse me if that
was a curse word but in the end we have
never been better off as Republicans to
go against Joe Biden he is incompetent
Network okay 91 percent of the people
are concerned about inflation extremely
housing paying bills taxes the Border
crime and the Republicans decide now
it's time let's sink what sink uh
McCarthy that's baloney
yeah that's baloney hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else